do you have plans to visit the southern
border uh i've been there before and i
haven't i mean i know it well i guess i
should go down but the
but the whole point of it is i haven't
had a whole hell of a lot of time to get
down there's been uh reporting that he
did drive through the border when he was
on the campaign trail in 2008 he does
not need a visit to the border to know
what a mess was left by the last
administration
well
the white house saying he drove past the
border during the 2008 campaign
and
saying even though he said that maybe he
should go down that he didn't really
mean the president didn't in that town
hall that he he would go down town hall
needed to be cleaned up today by the
white house press secretary in a couple
of different points meantime gallup the
approval analysis
for gallup says that biden's average
third quarter job approval rating is
down eight points from his second
quarter 53 11 points from his first
quarter rating of 56. this 11-point
decline is larger than any prior
president registered between his first
and third quarters although it is
similar to those for the last three
democratic presidents barack obama uh
clinton and carter
so let's bring in our panel ben dominic
publisher of the federalist harold ford
jr former tennessee congressman and ceo
of empowerment inclusion capital and
jason riley wall street journal
columnist and senior fellow at the
manhattan institute jason there were a
number of incidents that the white house
had to clarify and we pointed them out
here the border uh the situation about
gas prices and maybe most importantly
about taiwan
yes there are there are a number of
issues going on here i would add to that
brett the the spending debate going on
on congress right now
um
and i think joe biden's problem is that
he's trying to present this
as a democrat versus republican issue
when in reality particularly with regard
to the spending bill it's a democrat
versus democrat
problem he can't get his own ducks
in a row and you have a debate going on
between
progressives in the democratic party and
more moderates in the democratic party
on how to spend this this the spending
bill that they want to unleash
and it frankly boils down to their
ambitions being
greater than their actual mandate that
the the american people did not elect a
progressive president to pursue a
progressive agenda and biden is trying
to slip one by the american people
the washington post herald writes it
this way about that town hall president
biden had one central message for
disappointed progressives at his cnn
town hall last night please be patient
the problem with biden's promises to
come back to progressive priorities is
that his razor thin democratic
majorities in the house and senate won't
be any bigger and republicans won't be
any more inclined to go along which is
why progressives have been urging him
for months to fight to get rid of the
filibuster something he said he might
actually be for now
well thanks for having me on that this
is i think jason nailed it with with the
frame
progressives didn't and don't have a
massive majority in the house
or even a comfortable majority in the
house for that matter the senate i think
when we elected president biden the
country did they they were neglecting
someone they thought would bring a level
of stability and maturity and experience
to decision making into the white house
and to jason's point the president has
spent most of his time trying to referee
disputes between and amongst his own
party members i've said for some time
democrats take the victory give the
country what they've asked for which is
an infrastructure bill demonstrate that
you can govern and lead and then come
back and do the other things which i
think at some point president biden's
going to have to say to democrats in a
forthright way i hope he doesn't have to
say in a forthright way with an outcome
in virginia that is detrimental to my
party terry mcauliffe has asked for
democrats to give us this victory and
give us a chance
to lead in the government to lead in the
government in the majority which is the
way you actually enact policy so until
they do that i think it's going to be
hard for my party i don't see how it's
going to get done before that virginia
election but we'll see i mean they may
try to put the pedal to the metal but it
seems like there are really big sticking
points i mentioned the filibuster change
and the evolution of the president how
he's talked about it take a listen to
that evolution
i'm trying to bring the country together
and i don't want the debate to only be
about whether or not we have a
filibuster if it's a relic of jim crow
it's been used to fight against civil
rights legislation historically why
protect it there's no reason to protect
it other than you're going to throw the
entire congress into chaos and nothing
will get done all right nothing at all
will get done
and there's a lot at stake i also think
we're going to have to move to the point
where we fundamentally alter the
filibuster that remains to be seen
exactly what that means in terms of
fundamentally altering it and whether or
not we just end the filibuster straight
up
that's quite an evolution ben
how different your attitude is when you
move from the senate to the white house
toward the filibuster you know an
essential defense of american
representative politics or just a
nuisance to be wiped away
look i think that what harold said is is
correct in the sense that the
progressives don't have a majority here
they don't even have anything close to
it
and yet what this represents what this
massive spending uh package represents
at this point is an attempt to try to
satisfy virtually every progressive
priority even in ways that are sloppy
and don't make sense from fiscal policy
perspectives if you add a smaller policy
package you might be able to have
something that was more permanent more
long-standing instead you're likely to
end up if anything ends up passing at
all with a package that is more easily
swept away potentially by a future
republican majority and i think that
democrats are really waking up to the
fact that
while individual parts of this plan may
test well when they're polled and when
they are asked of the american people
as a whole this plan is not something
that the american people are all that
excited about and they don't really
believe it's going to satisfy the
problems that they see every day when it
comes to inflation when it comes to
their pocketbook and certainly when it
comes to the increasingly controversial
issues related to education which are so
key in this virginia race jason i only
have a few seconds here but i was struck
by the gas answer from president biden
last night at that town hall and that
essentially his hands are tied and that
gas prices are going up
into next year
saying that a lot depends on opec and
saudi arabia
republicans would point out that a lot
would happen in the previous
administration to
free the u.s
from foreign oil and that we're back in
the place we were before that
you're right and and what biden isn't
telling you that his progressives are
happy with high energy costs to the
extent that it pushes people towards
renewables towards this
green new deal type policies and so
forth they have no problem with uh
fossil fuel energy prices going up but
the american people do the voters do it
again
joe biden was not elected to transition
us off fossil fuels even if that's what
the progressives want
which is a big contention in that last
debate hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else